it's one year now I left my accounting
job right I was working at the CPA firm
and I was on the clear path to becoming
a partner in The Firm like I felt like I
was living somebody else's life cuz
looking at them sitting behind the desk
nobody looked happy they all looked okay
but nobody looked happy you tell them I
don't want to be you basically no I
didn't say that but that was a message
in my head I said no I I don't see
myself being here I don't see myself
doing that in the next 5 years the next
10 years so I might as well get out of
it right now and so I made the I took
the decision that most people wouldn't
take cuz you have clear pass to this
number of dollars in your bank account
every single month and you say no to it
just because it's so I walked out of
that all right we're here with Ida part
of the Mastermind and so part of that we
do a one-on-one together so what's going
on how can I help okay so I did
everything you told me to do okay great
which is I got my team so right now I do
have a video editor I do have a personal
assistant and I am training for um
accounting associate this is in the past
month yes nice let's go I as an action
taker great yes so I want to know what
next for me what should I be doing next
what should I be focusing on next in
order to because a bigger mission is
actually to to to empower well there's
two missions number one is to empower
especially hot Center entrepreneurs to
help them with the accounting the
bookkeeping the taxes and stuff like
that but I don't necessarily want to be
doing it on and on I want to train
people who can take first of all take
care of all of the bookkeeping side of
things yeah and then it's going to free
me to then take the people who can do
the higher level accounting stuff and
that way once they're doing all of that
then I can move on to the other Mission
which is helping um like Tik Tok I have
like 15,000 people following me there
and they follow me because of my other
messages on financial education personal
finance side of things so those are the
people that in the bigger mission in the
future those are the people that want to
continue to help but also at the same
time helping the entrepreneurs with all
the the accounting and bookkeeping stuff
through the the system that I'm setting
up so so the accounting pays the pays
the bill brings in the money the the
personal finance is a longer term
Mission but not as clear business model
attached to it right okay only Canada
only Canada but across Canada yes when
you say Obviously you want to bring on
people to actually do the work does that
mean you want it under your umbrella
you're managing them or you're taking
pieces of their business and they're
running their own companies two ways
so the side of the people that I'm
currently bringing in right now the
accounting Associates those are directly
under me and they're going to continue
to do it under me and I know what spoken
before and you talked about the other
model which was to get other people that
I could mentor and train and Coach so
that they can they can do it on the
their own business side of things um
it's been hard finding those people and
so that's why I went with the other one
of bringing in the associates under me
lower level under me so it's it's
they're just two different models
there's no like right or wrong it's more
like what do you want to build do you
want to do you want to build the company
where you
are you have employees and they're just
doing their job or do you want to build
a company where you have a bunch of
entrepreneurs and you're just mentoring
and coaching the entrepreneurs can I do
both uh sure I mean so with all of these
can you do both yes but it's like this
and this and my personal finance message
on Tik Tok and other platforms it's it's
so the more you do many things the less
stuff happens typically right I want to
make sure that the people that I'm
bringing onto the team are people who
understand the vision and are a great Fe
culture feed and all of that so yeah
either way like whether you hire them to
be under you as employees or you're
partner with entrepreneurs and mentoring
and training them either way they have
to be a good because they represent your
brand either way right so when you have
employees it's like you're doing it
here's my way this is what we're doing
you're bringing on a different mindset
of person who's kind of clocking in and
clocking out and they're getting their
job done and then they're off living
their life versus an entrepreneur who
may not always do it exactly the same
way that you want to do it you're
guiding and mentoring but they're
running their own business and you're
you're coach as opposed to like actually
running the business so there's no like
right or wrong it's more what's more
interesting what feels better where do
you want to play so here's what I'm
looking at for me to be able to bring on
those entrepreneurs cuz I tried it right
brought on like five people who were
meant to be entrepreneurial individuals
who would then learn the methods and
then go out and Implement on their own
in their own businesses but I never
really got them to be able to to know
how to do it or know what to do and it
might be me it might just be I didn't
find the right people and I have to go
back and find the people but the problem
with that was in the process of trying
to find those people it was taken away
from the time of doing the actual client
work that I already had hanging there
and so I had to pull back on that in
order to then find the people who can
continue to do the existing client work
which would then free me up to go and do
the other part of it right okay but so
you're there right you hired the
people now it's okay is that enough of a
base to then go and build this other
thing or do I want to build my base to
be bigger because when you're hiring an
employee especially for something like
accounting it's pretty black and what
you need there's rules you follow the
rules you have your methodology of
course customer service and values and
all that but it's it's relatively easy
to find somebody to kind of jump in and
do the work when you're talking about
building an entrepreneur and partner
with them when it's way more creative
like that it's more work it's work to
figure things out and just because like
the first five didn't workout doesn't
mean that like if you want on five dates
with people doesn't mean like oh I guess
I'm never gonna
being in a
relationship right like especially at
the beginning right your first five days
are probably terrible M maybe your first
for grade uh but it's probably not great
right and like you learn as you go so
it's messy yes you know but you have to
like the messiness so if I if you look
at me as an example we're sitting here
at tronto Salsa right this is an example
of the business where the idea is I own
a piece of it Alex is going to own most
of it and he runs it and I'm just
coaching Alex does he do everything I
tell him to do
no we're looking at it right now you
know like would is he building it the
same way I would build it hell no right
yeah but we need to build it around him
and I need to manage his personality as
opposed to saying like I don't want to
come in and say Alex you didn't show up
and like at nine o'clock you didn't do
this and 10 o'clock you didn't do this
and just tell him how to be uh a mini
Evan like it's part finding his way and
so you know we've got three different
YouTube agencies and then a podcast
agency and then the dance studio but
even the three YouTube agencies aren't
run the exact same way same principle
same methodology same like accounting
you have to you can't take liberties
with the tax code right I
mean so there's still rules that you
have to operate in but how they run it
and how they do their day-to-day is
completely different and some people
like working with you know Jeremy more
than Drew or Zach more than Jeremy
whatever um but it's messy you know even
here on the bench we can't see we've got
ji we got uh Dominic on the side I'm
trying to figure out something to do
with them I don't know what it is yet
you know Dominic is an awesome video uh
producer editor Creator and we're trying
to figure out like what is the what is
the model that's that would work uh he
loves storytelling okay how do we tell
better stories but I don't know I don't
know I don't have the answer so hey come
come I invite him to the stuff that I do
and then like we're trying to find a way
to make something work right um chiaki's
from India just moved here a year ago uh
Halifax comes here she messaged me we
don't even know what we're doing you
know just I liked her vibe and I liked
her message so I like you know what if
you can come to
Toronto for three days I'm doing this
thing there's no like official role but
come out and hang out and see what we do
and maybe we'll find a path right so
it's very
gray now she could have said no he could
have said no cool great you know they
other people say no perfect but when
they say yes then it's okay they're
saying yes what what do they see and how
do we like I can't just tell them here's
what to do because then just be hiring
an employee I'm trying to co-create
something okay so it's messy yeah right
when you have to be comfortable with the
messy and the beginning sometimes is
fast and sometimes is super slow and
we're kind of dancing together right I
like that a lot more actually I like the
messiness and I like trying to figure
stuff out I like the gray a lot more
because that's where you get to be a lot
more creative and I like seeing I like
seeing entrepreneurs grow like seeing
Alex grow as an entrepreneur has been
amazing yeah and so it's just it's a
question of Personality what do you what
do you want to do what do you like the
most uh both models can work like every
business model can work but which one's
going to work for you you tried it it
didn't work you came back and said okay
I need to I'm losing money because I
don't have my like I'm not serving my
clients now you figured that out you
hired your team to serve your current
clients right yeah okay cool the next
step is do you build a bigger base and
if you you know you're probably not
going to 10x your clients and 10x your
employee base as your next step but do
you 2X like do you do you double what
you're doing right now do you hire three
more people to serve the new clients you
come on I think I can 3x the business on
the people that I have right
now okay so is that that's a logical
step to do okay does it how excited is
it to do for the base yes it's good to
be able to have that stability on the
side knowing that you can go off and do
your crazy entrepreneurial ideas and you
have that base coverage so I think it's
a good idea for me to to use using the
base that I have right now let them
continue to serve the current clients
possibly bring on more clients that they
can handle and then with that settled
and they are trained and they are doing
it in my way because it's my employees
yeah I can then go on and do because
this one is definitely more exciting
like like I don't I don't do logical
things it's like I want to I want to go
out and do the thing that's not logical
that's your that's your next
Instagram I don't do logical things Ida
well it's true EV I never I don't know
if I ever told you about how I left the
the job I was working at it's one year
now I left my accounting job right I was
working at the CPA firm and I was on a
clear path to becoming a partner in The
Firm like I sat there and I looked at my
manager when he was talking to me like
either you could you could become a
partner here and I looked at him I was
like I felt like I was living somebody
else's life because looking at them
sitting behind the desk nobody looked
happy they all looked okay but nobody
looked happy tell them I don't want to
be you basically no I didn't say
that but that was a message in my head I
said no I like I don't see myself being
here in the knck I don't see myself
doing that in the next five years the
next 10 years so I might as well get out
of it right now and so I made the I took
the decision that everybody would most
people wouldn't take cuz you have this
clear path to this number of dollars in
your bank account every single month and
you say no to it just because it's so I
walked out of that and so I don't want
to bury myself in the same model right
now and if I expand what I'm doing doing
right now then I'm going back to that I
want to build a model where they can do
the work with the base that I have or
expand on the work that they can do
while I go out on the entrepreneurial
side to to help other people because I
know how to do it but I just the set of
time I just don't want to do it so I
want to train people on how to to do
things well okay so listen if you can 3x
your business with your current staff
then that's an easy next step to start
the work to whether it's 1X or 2x or 3x
or 2 and a half or whatever you know
that there'll be a point where it's like
you just don't even want want to bring
on more clients or you start firing some
clients and bring on just better fit
clients or better culture clients cool
so now you have your base and it's a
growing base you know you you doubled
your base cool now what do you do with
that do you want to go and do the
entrepreneur invest an idea or do you
want to spend your time on the personal
finance side and really build that
up because the home base is kind of
taken care of and you're making enough
to support yourself plus build team to
help you do whatever the next thing is
the personal finance is fun yeah but
there's no I don't see a model around
that where it could monetize so to speak
but the entrepreneurial side of
mentoring and coaching people definitely
has a part in you that I could see so
you know it's uh not letting the what's
the quote not letting the path to a
clear
goal help you play small compared to the
path to an unclear goal yeah yeah you
know it's like we play small because we
don't know how to accomplish our big
things and we settle for the small thing
yeah which which is fine in the in the
I'm going to I'm going to 2x or 3x my
business knowing that this is a base is
going to help me do my big thing but the
big thing is is unclear and that's also
okay like the the whole point of
building the base to 3x is that you
don't have to have the next thing make
you a ton of money yet yeah but it'll
lead opportunities
so personal
finance being a thought leader there's
lots of options there's lots of models
that have already been proven out you
have to build the base right you have to
take it more seriously you have to
create more content you have to be more
powerful in your opinions you like
there's a lot of work that has to get
done but it's not that nobody has ever
done it so you make money from Brand
deals from sponsorships from speaking
gigs from ad revenue from book launch
from your own products like the thing is
you won't know where you're going to
make the money until you start getting
into it you can have a plan but you
won't know until you get into it because
as you're get into it maybe you realize
that the biggest thing missing is the
the there a tool like the the tools
right now suck and so you end up
partnering with a tool company and
taking 10% of their business and helping
them blow up like Ryan Reynolds did and
you know now the actor but
oh he well he went from acting right Ron
R Reynolds and then he invested in uh
was it mint I forget which company it
was anybody you know was it mint anyway
like a finance soft software company but
in finance and just like had a huge exit
and then he did it again I think in the
alcohol Market somewhere in again Big
Exit uh but it's like you don't know
that that's gonna happen but it might
yeah you know there's some awesome new
tool that is making personal finances so
much easier and you become the face for
it and they give you 10% and they sell
for a billion dollars like that's the
stuff that starts to happen right not
that you can't you can't plan
necessarily for that to happen but those
are the things that happen if you become
a name brand yeah so who are the people
in personal finance if it's like if it's
Dave Ramsey or Susie Orman or whoever
they get tons of opportunities thrown at
them because they are a brand name in
personal finance yeah there there's lots
of opportunities but you don't know how
it's going to shake up and so that's
where we often play small because we
have a clear path to a lesser goal but
if you're already making 3x the money
and that supports you it allows you to
take shots at things that are a little
more scary because it doesn't have to
pay off in the next two years it might
but it doesn't have to right so if that
was like what would you rather spend
your time doing like I I really love co-
chain entrepreneurs it's really fun for
me I like I like my Mondays doing
that it's probably not the biggest
upside compared to what I could be doing
if I look at opportunities you know like
helping Alex grow TDs is is probably not
the best use of my time right if I'm
just looking at numbers right but I like
it so not everything always works out to
uh X's and O's um and it and it can
create lots of other opportunities that
I can can't even see yet so I'm I'm all
in on doing things that you love and
great things will happen while also
protecting your base and making sure
that you have money to survive so if
your home base is taken care of when you
you know the path to be able to twox
your business I mean that's not really a
hard problem to solve right no to get
two times three times as many clients
you can do that just a matter of doing
good work getting referrals like it's
not worth spending a ton of time
brainstorming that I mean unless you
want to no but to L it's a it's a 3X
it's a small goal 10x yeah like what a
you know what a privileged place to be
in right it's like I've got this
business I've got this team and yeah
like growing three times is easy right
like that's a for most entrepreneurs
that's uh that's the whole problems like
how do I get started how I can't you
quit your job a year ago a lot of people
like how do I quit my job and make
enough money to support myself now you
quit your job you've hired four people
or whatever and now you're yeah growing
three times is easy right it's a great
place to be able to be in cool you know
how to do that now what is the thing
that you want to spend your time on do
you want to invest in entrepreneurs or
do you want to go build a personal
finance
brand eventually personal finance okay
so you don't have to actively go after
the middle step the entrepreneur one
unless you find the right person and you
want to do something with them and just
go build the personal finance stuff like
what's missing in personal finance right
now what what is Susie Orman not saying
and Dave Ramsey not saying and everybody
else not saying Susie Orman I'm not very
familiar with her work uh but Dave
Ramsey is I love him he he's the one who
got me started on everything I followed
his baby steps and but what's he missing
he's already talking he's out there
what's wrong with Dave Ramsey Dave
Ramsey is is um he pushes a lot of well
he pushes a lot of mutual funds but
there there's a lot of truths that are
not know known about mutual funds um
he's completely against credit but there
the lots of ways to use credit that are
good for you it's just about learning
how to use it properly most people never
learned how to use it and so they get
into the mess that he talks about which
is what I got into as well as a newcomer
when I came into Canada that Financial
education I didn't get and so my process
of becoming what what I am today was
much delayed because I didn't get the
education that I needed and so I do see
a lot of people who still come in as
newcomers just like me and knowing
nothing about it and when when newcomers
come here they do have a lot of
potential cuz to be taken from or to be
accepted into Canada especially is a
professional from another country coming
here it means you've got something to
offer but a lot of them come here and
they cannot offer that because by the
time they can figure out a community
figure out a society to be able to do
what it is they need to do they're
already in a mess so to get out of that
place it's like it's it's just hard to
get out so if if people can get the educ
that they need at the time they get in
then it sets them up in a place where
they can then go out and create the
impact that can actually create in the
world without having to get into a hole
before getting out of it so the there's
no message directly going towards that
population of people following me on on
on Tik Tok but at the same time I hadn't
figured out a way to be able to monetize
that side of things cuz the people
needed the message the message I was
passing along didn't in a way were
already in a ho they didn't have the M
the money to afford to pay me for the
work that I'm doing that is the the the
goal that got delayed or the side of the
business that I was like okay I could
eventually do the other things I'm doing
so I could get the fin finances so I
could get the base that would allow me
to go out and spread this message out
there even if I'm doing it for free so
it the challenge had been figuring out a
way to get paid for that side of things
there's a huge population needing it
there's nobody actually serving that
market pery or maybe there is but this
the people who need the message aren
getting it maybe because the people
preaching the message don't look like
them don't sound like them don't they
don't come from the same backgrounds as
them so I am that person that a lot of
people resonate with my message because
I've been there and I've gotten out of
it and now they can see me as an
inspiration doing the things that I do
and so it's it's that that like Dave
Ramsey is a very big inspiration for me
I love what he does like he got me in a
in a large to a large extent he got me
out of the hole um but I'm back to using
credit cards not because I don't know
how to use it or not because I need it
but just because it's a tool and people
need to learn that and so there's
there's a lot of disconnects like I
learned a lot from um Robert Kaki
reached up that he is all about credit
dve Ram is completely against there's a
middle ground there it's about knowing
what it is that needs to be done so
there's that side of things which is
missing which I can I can take care of
uh but like I mentioned the challenge to
that was the finance getting the
finances getting those people to be able
to afford to pay for it so in my mind
eventually that's something that I'm
going to go back to and I still put bits
and pieces of that into the content that
I create all the time but the people
that I currently serve the people who
can pay me the people who I'm able to
help right now
uh entrepreneurs on the accounting and
that's that's the be that I'm building
with my
team even just like I don't know how
long you talk for there was great but
like that rant that you went on uh that
like that's what you want to
do you can see that that's what you want
to do yeah so Now's the Time to start
doing
it okay and having faith that it will
work out if you continue to put in the
effort there's a lot of work that has to
get done there's you know clarifying the
message having more powerful opinions
all of that but it's possible and you
have the energy you know like when I
when I ask you a simple question on that
and you go on this five minute you know
rant I think I started with Dave Ramsey
or something then when but then I asked
you about the entrepreneurs and it like
wasn't as uh it's more strategy yeah
than anything else which is fine but
there's you already have a good strategy
to make money which is go sell to the
entrepreneurs who need accounting help
and you already know how to two 3x your
business with your current team so like
go do that and start to build either of
the personal finance
expert okay and and then it's just
condensing in the time frame so it's not
at some point out in the future I'm
going to get back to that it's like okay
we're getting back to that
now
okay if you can cry that's fine think of
how fast you've moved in the past month
right like we met a month ago in
Montreal and you're like I'm trying to
hire somebody and then you went off and
now you have your
team with which you can triple your
business and that gives you everything
you need yeah and now there's people who
are struggling who don't know how to get
out of the hole that they're in and
don't want to listen to Dave or can't
hear his message or it doesn't work for
them and they don't know who to turn
to there people you know the what does
Les say the story that you're sitting on
people are waiting on yeah people are
waiting on you to to do it and now you
actually can you know if you said a
couple months ago or a year ago it's
like okay it's some fun hobby little
thing part-time but now you can actually
do it as you continue to build your base
you can actually do it and like people
are waiting on
you so not not sometime in the future
but let's go
Ida all right okay I got ladies and
gentlemen to watch me coach another
Mastermind member oneon-one check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you probably don't
need more learning you need more courage
more boldness to do the thing and this
is where a lot of people will get stuck
up as like oh I need to learn more
there's so many people like if learning
was the only thing that mattered then
University professors would all be